All right, Gadi Bashvitz,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thanks Michael.
Where are you calling from?
It looks like Meteora, Greece
but I think I'm wrong.
Actually,  the picture behind me
it's from Telluride, Colorado.
But I'm in Corte Madera.
So, eight miles north
from the Golden Gate Bridge right now.
Oh, you're eight miles
of the Golden Bridge. Wonderful
The picture is the picture I took over
July 4th, last weekend last year.
Last year. Wonderful.
Actually, I believe this episode
is gonna air sometime later on.
So maybe it will be
last weekend, July 4th.
We'll see.
Gadi, extensive experience
in the tech sector
from 8200 to your MBA at NYU,
leading the entrepreneurship segment there
going on to Verint.
VP at NICE.
Your own startup which you've already
co-founded before,
and now you're a part of NeuraLegion
another startup.
Take me through your journey
just a little bit.
Give me a brief of who is Gadi.
All right.
Happy having to start there.
Maybe I'll even start a bit earlier.
Wonderful.
Or that. I'm originally from Israel,
but I got to grow up
in a bunch of different countries.
Which always makes it fun.
That instilled the love of travel in me.
I've been to 110 countries.
Wait wait wait.
You've been to a 110 countries?
Okay, throw everything else
out the window.
I just wanna talk about that.
What does it mean 110?
Since I stop travel,
it's funny because I was talking to
the one of our [--] yesterday
and he said,
"Yeah, I'd like to go to New Zealand."
And I started on the call
with the whole plan for him.
I'm like,
"Okay, this is what you need to do."
"You need to go there."
"This is how you do it."
"This is how you travel."
That's how I usually end up conversations.
I'm a travel agent
to anybody who knows me.
Gadi, this is incredible.
How do you get to 110 countries?
Well, a lot of it is
growing up in Europe as a kid.
My parents used to throw us
in the back of the car
and just drive around.
So, I've been to about 30 countries
by the age of 10.
And then you just fall in love with it
and you find jobs over time
that let you travel
and go see a lot of other places.
So, in the period between,
we're getting a bit off topic
but I think that's okay.
In a period between 2001 and 2012,
I travelled 2.2 million miles
and visited about 70 different countries.
So, mostly for work, but I got to
extend that and have some fun.
Wow. Okay.
That's just incredible.
Going back to entrepreneurship,
but we're gonna continue,
we're continuing this
right after the recording.
Okay. Excellent.
So, started there.
I came back to Israel
after a few years in Europe.
8200, the customary plan
for anybody in cyber.
Then got my undergrad
at Tel Aviv University.
And went in to join
this world of high tech.
Founded my first startup in '99
after my first company
that's acquired by NICE.
That's a very interesting time
to start a company.
It was a very,
actually it was a great time
to start a company.
And fortunately, two years later,
we have lost a great time
to raise a series A,
which is what we were in the midst of.
But things actually went pretty well
and we ended up selling the company.
It's a strange story.
We actually split it in two
and NICE acquired part of it
and Verint acquired another part.
And I went to one place
and my partner and co-founder
went to the other place.
Wow.
And that's how I joined there.
I was with them on the product side
for about a year and a half in Israel.
And then they moved me to the US
as part of the extension of the company.
And Verint was a fund run.
I was there for six years.
We went from 150 people
to 2500 people.
We went public.
We went from about $15 million in sales
to $400 million in sales.
What was your role in the company
as you were watching this
incredible transition?
I was running product design
and the product management organization.
And then when I moved here,
I started the pre-sales group,
then a business consulting group
and then customer success.
I did some direct sales.
So,I got to see everything
from the front line.
It was very interesting to work
on a very large opportunity.
So, selling to, first of all,
the IRS here in the US, then AT&T,
T-Mobile, Sprint, some of the large banks,
working on deals anywhere from
$10 million to $40 million.
This is pre-tax.
So, that was an exciting period.
And I learned a lot.
In parallel,
what you brought up earlier
is I got my MBA at NYU.
Right.
That was my weekend job.
And around the Entrepreneurship Club.
for me to promote exchange,
Even though I was a part time student,
I really wanted to get involved.
Found an apartment
a block and a half away from Stern.
And that enabled me
to really get involved there.
But alas, after six years
in the Verint company,
I got a bit too big
after a big acquisition we did.
And I decided it was time to move on
and join a company called
Merced Systems here on the West Coast.
I moved at the end of 2007
to San Francisco.
I joined Merced pretty early on.
We were 25 people.
Something like that at the time.
Pretty small.
And when five years later
we were acquired by NICE.
The great thing about Merced is that
we only raised one round of funding.
We only raised
two and a half million dollars
and we were profitable from year two.
Oh my God. Wait. So, that was
the second company you're involved with
that Nice was involved
in the acquisition, right?
Exactly.
Wow. Interesting. Coincidence?
It's all in the same space.
On the same space.
So, yes and no.
Interesting. Gadi, I wanna give time
to talk about cyber security
because this is also a sweet spot for me
after my own five years in 8200.
NeuraLegion.
I'm a part of J-Ventures.
So so proud to be a part of the fund
that helped invest in NeuraLegion.
Give me the pitch.
What is NeuraLegion?
Why is app security so prevalent
and so important in 2020?
Yeah, absolutely.
I think the key thing that we do,
or the key couple of things that we do
that are very different
and very innovative in the market is
we took the approach from the beginning.
From the time the company was created,
that we want to provide
a tool for developers.
We do not want to go
into the security organization
and tell them:
Here's the CYA tool
that you can go ahead and deploy.
And say that it will work
and you get the report that you need.
No. We wanted to provide a tool
to companies that they can integrate
very early on into their
development processes and make sure
that developers are using it.
But that's the reason we called it
from building to compliance.
Right.
So, it can be deployed on every build.
But you can build on that
and go from that to say,
"Okay, I've secured the build.
Now, I've secured the application.
Now, I've secured the product.
And now I get my compliance reports.
And you do that all in one holistic way
across all of your environments.
So, you're not just testing
your application,
but you're testing your API,
which is critical today.
More and more organizations
are using that.
You're using and your testing
your mobile applications
and also, any modern technology
that you're using, like:
single page applications,
or authenticated sites,
or if you're into
micro services environment,
we can support all that.
Because we are inherently
built in the cloud
and we're not a legacy solution.
Talk to me a little bit about
how do you grow a company like this?
Fine. So, you have great talent.
You understand the space.
You write a great solution.
Now what?
So, you have yeah,
you have a million SAS products,
but you're knocking on the doors.
You're offering another security,
another layer.
How do you sell this thing?
I think the critical thing is,
one, you need to understand
how you're different
and where you're different.
And this actually ties
into your other question of
how do you grow
still growing company,
even though that's not the case here.
But the key thing is focus.
How do you understand,
where are the opportunities
that you can actually win.
What are the opportunities
that you can't win.
And how to walk away
from the ones you can't win.
There's a lot of people,
at least the time of time and places
that ultimately will just waste their time
and they're not able to win.
But one of the things
and that's a critical thing
that I implemented
the minute I joined here
and many other companies, is,
we do not join a meeting
and do a demo of the first meeting, right?
All these companies join a meeting
and immediately start talking
at the customer.
Absolutely not.
Our first meeting is a discovery meeting.
You are going to talk to us
in the first meeting.
They will spend 15, 20 minutes
understanding what are
actual challenges are.
And once we know what they are
and then we'll come back, we'll prepare
and we'll present back to you.
If we think that we can't help you,
we will tell you that on the first call.
So, we don't waste your time or our time,
because that's our most
sacred resource, it's the time.
Of course. And is this diverging
from the common way that
any SAS company operates today?
I think that modern sales organizations
know this and they do that.
But go to any website
that you have, right?
And click it.
What is the call to action that they have?
Request to demo.
No, I don't believe in that.
You can request a demo,
you're not gonna get one immediately.
Right?
It's how you catch your people
and how you get them.
So, I think that
modern sales organizations
absolutely understand this.
I did not invent the concept
of asks questions first,
and learn and then adapt.
But it's something
that a lot of people get wrong
and that's how you get started.
Then you actually need
to have a superior product.
You need to be able to go off in POCs
and beat anybody in the competition.
I'm happy to say that we've done
20, 25 POCs in the last four months
and we've never lost.
We beat each and every one of them.
That's why we've invested.
That's why we're so proud.
Well, you invested
before these four months.
Yeah. Hopefully we'll follow on
[--]
We'll see major way.
By the time this airs,
To follow on will be bad.
Isn't this the role
of the investors, though,
to always then say,
"Yeah, I knew this before."
and that's how you're in?
All right. Gadi, one of the things
that we talked about right before starting
is this notion of,
taking a large company
or a large organization
and that is slowly growing
and understanding
how can we pivot to scale
so that we can go much quicker
than we can.
You had experience doublings,
sometimes the sales in like
periods of 18 months, which is incredible.
Talk to me a little bit about this notion.
What makes a company grow slow?
And what makes a company grow fast?
Yeah, I think it's touching on somebody
you already,
something we already talked about.
The key thing is what are the levers
that you can pull?
What do you need to stop doing?
First thing that you need
to understand is,
what do I need to stop doing?
I love it.
What am I doing that's just wasting time?
Okay, and I should not be doing
because even if I do it,
it won't help us grow, right?
And that's a critical, critical thing.
Once you understand
what you need to stop doing,
you need to understand
what are the levers that you can pull.
And really, there are few levers
in the area of sales that you can pull.
One is you can increase
your average contract value.
That's a very big one.
You need to understand
how do you do that.
You need to change your pricing models.
You need to change your go-to market.
You need to change the customer
you're selling to.
And you need to update
how you package the product, etc.
Right. That's one critical thing.
The next thing is,
can you change your sales cycle?
That there's something you're doing
in your sales cycle
that is preventing you from going faster.
And you have the ability
to now shorten that sales cycle
and have more impact.
The third one is,
how are you actually going to market?
Right. Are you going direct?
And are you having meetings in person?
This whole covid thing
that happened right now
is really teaching us that,
yes, you can do enterprise sales over Zoom
because somehow we've all
gotten comfortable doing that.
That's not something that organizations
were receiving or admitting
that can be done earlier.
But maybe that's the change.
But I was just having,
I was having coffee with a good friend
from the Stanford Business School.
And one of the things
he was telling me is,
You know, Michael,
one of the things that is happening,
a lot of really great salespeople,
it's not just about the demo
and about sitting
and about talking.
It's about the whole experience.
It's coming in.
Maybe going for a nice lunch
getting to know the other person.
Critical.
Well, you can't do that anymore.
Now, I can be sitting
in my underwear right now.
We don't know.
This is a whole different conversation.
I'm not in my underwear, just,
[--]
I think it is an interesting ride
because I have done
this huge enterprise sales
where in the end,
people buy from people, right?
And that is a very important component.
There are circumstances right now
that have changed that.
Do I think that ultimately
when this whole covid thing is over,
we will not revert a bit towards,
yes, still establishing relationships
and still having a drink together
for large enterprise deals
and still forming relationships
Absolutely not.
That is going to come back.
And quite frankly, it's one of the parts
of the job that I like.
So, it would be sad,
being a traveler
and love meeting people totally,
I love that.
All right.
It would be sad if that went away.
I don't believe it will.
But definitely you're learning
what kinds of opportunities
do not require that.
Amazing.
And how to differentiate between the two.
Why come back to early stage startups?
I'd say there are,
well, I was, I never left, really.
Apart from Verint,
which was a more mature company.
I always go back.
But you're also VP at NICE.
You're also a VP.
But that was both acquisition.
Okay.
So, I was there post acquisition
and helping the transition, etc.
So, I constantly come back
to early stage startups.
At some point,
I will stop doing that
because it is very very hard work.
But I would say for me, it's three things.
One, is really having the ability
to make an impact.
And at earlier stages,
every step that you do
has much more significant impact.
Right.
And that's one thing I love.
Two, in the case of NeuraLegion,
it was really going back to the origins.
I started in cybersecurity.
I thought it was time to go back to it.
I understand this market
and I really saw an opportunity
I can provide value.
And three, there were,
quite frankly, threats on my life.
One of my CEO is been my best friend
for 40 years,
and he told me that it was time for me
to come back and start working together.
How many opportunities do you get
to work with your best friend?
That's incredible.
That's just incredible.
You know, talk to me a little bit about
the cyber security space.
Where are we headed?
What are some of the greatest challenges
in this space as a whole,
not just NeuraLegion,
but the space as a whole
that you're seeing now as you're talking
to so many different companies
who are in need of cyber solutions?
Well, I think the market
is really shifting.
And it's shifted much more significantly
over the last three months
than people expected.
But this just pushed a lot of trends
that had already started.
The number of threats is
going up continuously, right?
It never stop.
And organizations are facing
new and more dangerous threats
all the time.
Now, especially with everybody
working from home, the whole,
would you believe three months ago
if I told you that VPN
is going to disappear
and there are new solutions
that will replace VPN.
We've been playing around with VPN
for 25 years now, right?
Unbelievable.
So, that's going away.
And there is a huge change.
And I think one of the biggest trends
that we're seeing is that,
really the world of software
is eating everything, right?
By Marc Andreessen. Yeah.
Software is eating the world.
Exactly. Right.
And now, that's coming
to security as well.
You can't have
two different organizations.
Now,  we're the security organization
that enforces up the development we're
gonna let you know.
That's wrong. Right?
They are one organization now.
And if you can't have security
from the ground up,
you're going to have a problem.
And we're seeing that in every single page
of every single part of cyber security.
And really, there is a great thing
in English which everybody knows, which is
"An ounce of prevention
is worth a pound of cure."
And integrating all these solutions
into the development process,
is that ounce of prevention.
It will save organizations a lot of money
and make them a lot more secure by design.
And that's exactly what
we're trying to help drive.
But it's not enough for any young company
to just come in and say,
"Yeah, we have a software."
Neuralegion and the few others
come along and integrate.
Let's be secure.
Are the companies as early as a POC
or an MVP,
do they already need somebody
who is knowledgeable with
cybersecurity space within the company?
Or do you think this can be outsourced
and just plug in installations
from other companies?
So, I think there are three options
that organizations can look at.
Because the threat profile is different
from different kinds of organization.
For a large and mature organization
and your Visa or your Citibank
or your government, you know
that there are a lot of people
that are excited to attack you.
So, you better have this in place
and you better have real experts in place
that are dynamic
and thinking on their feet
and know what they're doing.
If you're a midsize organization
that's developing a solution, etc,
or a very early stage company,
absolutely adapt these practices
they are the right practices
from the beginning.
Integrate them into your processes.
But you can use
third party tools for this.
The third approach,
which we're definitely seeing is
there are outsource companies
that help you with it.
And maybe it's taking a hybrid approach
in the first of the latter two
in order to really get secure as you grow.
I love it. Gadi, right before we leave,
and thank you again
for the time inspiration.
And I'm excited to continue learning
as much as I can from you along the way.
I need three words from you
that best describe you
and a little bit about
what are you truly passionate about?
Yeah. It's always a question
when you get asked this.
Is that how others would describe me
or how I'm going to describe myself?
I'm gonna let you choose which one.
I'll go with, and also, when I say others,
as my co-worker and my wife.
Who's the one that,
if the dog, then it's treat dispenser.
And that's as far as I go.
I would say Unconventional.
I don't necessarily do things
in the standard way
that they would be done otherwise.
Tenacious.
Okay. I like that.
And the one that I've heard of
time and time again that I like
is the GST. Get shit done.
I love it. Yes.
Talk is cheap.
Wonderful.
Gadi, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
And best of luck with everything.
[--]
Thank you very much.
Talk to you very soon. Bye bye.